على كل المزيد تنضم الينا زميلتنا سمر
بشات مراسله صباح العربيه اهلا بك يا
سماره عارفينه شلون صارت هي وقلتي سابقا
انه كثير من الناس ما بيعرفوا اصلا اتفضلي
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير فعلا كثير من الناس ما تعرفش
الفن الفن لطيف وصعب جدا دقيق يعني بتنقلي
الحياه والتراث حياتنا اليوميه بتنقليها
على حاجات اصغر من كف اليد معنا استاذ
عبير سعد الدين المصغراتيه ههه بتعمل
اشكال والوان هنوريها لكم دلوقت صباح
الخير صباح الخير اهلا بحضرتك الحمد لله
اولا عرفيني كده ايه فن ال- انت بتعملي
ايه اصلا المصغرات لان ممكن كثير ما
يعرفوش هو فعلا مصغرته عباره عن يعني
بنصغر اجزاء او مشاهد من الواقع
بالنسبه لي انا طبعا باشتغل على التراث
والمشاهد حياتيه يعني حاجات من الحياه
اليوميه بتاعه الناس يعني بس انا يعني
استغليت ده فكره ان انا باعمل يعني وقفات
كده من التراث او باخذ مشاهد من التراث
المصري العربي
[موسيقى]
اوكي همم في بيوت في الريف بيوت في النوبه
همم زي الاشكال اللي موجوده في مثلا زي
اوضه المسافرين اوضه الديون همم كانت لها
كده الوان وزخارف وقطع الاساس لها طابع
مميز بيميزنا يعني احنا ك- كتراس مصري
المطبخ والبابور الجاز والمخرطه والملوخيه
الخامات اللي بتشتغلي بها ايه الخامات
اللي بيستغلها همم اغلبها خشب وباعتمد
بالدرجه الاولى على الريسكل ريسايكل اعاده
التدوير لكل ما هو مخلفات في البيئه ورق
كرتون علب الكاندات غطيان الازايز همم
بقايا لعب الاطفال المتكسره همم كل ما هو
بواقي قماش بواقي خيوط استخدامات ال-
المصغرات دي يعني هل دي قطعه ديكور الناس
تحطها في بيتها ولا ممكن يبقى لها
استخدامات يوميا يعني انا شايفه نوت بوك
بصي هو دائما السؤال ده انا باتساله هو
انتم بتعملوا ايه ردي او ايه لزمتها يعني
همم فكرت كثير قوي هي ال- الاساس بتبقى زي
قطعه ديكور فكرت كثير قوي لحد ما انا بدات
اعملها وظائف كمان سهله كل الناس تقدر
تستخدمها هي ممكن تبقى عليقه مفاتيح ده
برج الجدي عملته على شكل علاقه مفاتيح
اوكي ويستخدم لان سمعته من النحاس وطليته
بميه الذهب فبقت نتيجه كده ممكن يبقى هديه
لطيفه جدا او احد يعني يقتني اوكي همم
ممكن يبقى ندبك زي كده زي ما حضرتك همم
يبقى غلاف النوت بوك عباره عن همم البيت
مجسم 3d
انا برده همم حسب عرفت بيستخدم ساعات في
السينما يعني في مثلا افلام وبرامج شون ذا
شيب بتاع الاطفال وفي هل انت بتشتغلي برده
مع السينما او مع المسلسلات لا هو الحقيقه
يعني ما عملتش ده بس هو فعلا بيستخدم
وبيوفر فلوس كثير جدا في الانتاج لانه
الجاتوهات بتكون مكلفه همم لو هو بنى او
احنا بنينا يعني ده همم بيبقى بيوفر وبيدي
نتايج حلوه جدا وكانها واقعيه همم يعني
كان في تجربه كده بس ما كملتش للاسف كان
همم هتعرض علي يعني ان انا اعمل لهم
ماكيتات في مسلسل استاذ محمد رمضان
ويعني ما
كملتي يعني لان الوقت كان ضيق جدا والشغل
ده بياخذ وقت كبير جدا
سؤال اخير الصعوبات بتاعه همم الشغلانه دي
ايه انا يعني انا اكيد عشان تعملي حاجه
صغننه كده صعبه ههه
بقى لي اربع سنين باشتغل فيها بس هي بتاخذ
وقت كبير جدا ومجهود كبير جدا معناها
صغيره بس بتاخذ وقت ومجهود وبتحتاج يعني
قوه عضليه اكثر ههه
[موسيقى]
تمام اا شكرا لكم على فكره هي عاده بيبقى
الشغل اصعب من كده بس هي مشغله بحاجات
بسيطه عشان التصوير اااه يعني حقيقي فن
ممتع جدا شكرا جزيلا لك سمر وضيفتك
الكريمه من القاهره شكرا سمر
[موسيقى]